على ينضم الينا يوسف زين الدين متحدث من
فريق شاهد يوسف منورنا في رمضان هالمره
اهلا وسهلا باعمال شاهد انا يعني مبسوط
اليوم معكم بالمساء دايما متعادينكم مع
بعض بالصباح احنا مبسوطين اكثر كمان صباح
ومساء طيب نتحدث يا يوسف عن اكثر الاعمال
مشاهده وتراند وحققت ارقام قياسيه من حيث
المشاهدات على شهد فعلا شفنا مع علاء قبل
شوي افضل الاعمال اللي كانت بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه انا جبت لكم كمان بعض
الاعمال اخترت دولتين صراحه اللي هم مصر
والامارات العربيه المتحده كمان افضل خمس
اعمال كانت موجوده عندهم زي ما حكى علاء
جعفر العمده وانتم حكيتوا كمان ببدايه
الفقره انه احتل المركز الاول
وبدوله الامارات واخيرا كان بالمركز
الثاني قصي خولي ونادين نجيم عم نشوف
الثنائي مره ثانيه مع بعض واخيرا الزند
تيم حسن كمان بالمرتبه الثالثه بالامارات
للموت بالجزء الثالث مستمر ومن اول ما طلع
بالجزء الاول وهو دائما كان بالمراكز
الاولى الاشهر لعامر سعد كمان من
المسلسلات بالمراكز الخمسه الاولى
بالامارات اما في مصر كامل العدد اللي
انتهى والكل بيقدر هلا يحضره صار بالكامل
15 صار كامل العدد على شاهد ومحتل المركز
الاول بمصر بنسب المشاهده الحرشه السابعه
لامينه خليل كمان محتار المركز الثاني
بمصر
برضو عم بيحكي عن قصص الازواج وكيف بعد
سبع سنوات من الزواج هل الحب رح ينتصر ولا
الروتين والمشاكل والتحديات الزوجيه
الصفاره وفكرته كيف انه بصفار بنقدر نرجع
الزمن فالمسلسل هذا الموضوع ورشيد والمداح
بالمرتبه الرابعه والخامسه